bonjour régis merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france la france ses
alliés européens dans ta coups bas et le
canada annonce d'un retrait coordonné du
mali c'est un communiqué en de l'elysée
ce matin qui poursuit en disant que les
partenaires internationaux au sahel
veulent je cite étendre leur soutien aux
pays du golfe de guinée comment est-ce
que vous analysez ces premières annonces
en attendant évidemment la conférence de
presse des manuels macron qui devrait
intervenir d'ici quelques instants
disons c'est c'est quelque chose qui
était en gestation depuis des mois voir
au moins un an qu'on sentait bien que
depuis les crispations avec les
autorités maliennes depuis finalement le
deuxième butch et opéré donc au mali les
relations entre la france et le mali ne
pouvait pas rester en l'état il avait
déjà évolué emmanuel macron annonçant
genre l'année dernière la fin de
l'opération par cannes donc prévue pour
2022 donc dans ce car en effet dans une
une logique une suite est également le
fait que le redéploiement de barkan
avait correspondu à une un repli d'une
certaine façon sur la zone des trois
frontières donc avec sur les trois bases
donc gossi gao et ménaka c'est à dire
donc cette cette bande de terre où se
trouve une grosse partie concentrée une
grosse partie de l'activité jihadistes
et en particulier de celles de leurs
richesses donc l'état islamique au grand
sahara désigné par la france comme
l'ennemi prioritaire au mali donc il y a
voilà il ya une sorte de suite mais en
même temps un sentiment profond que les
choses se sont tendues ont évolué de
façon imprévisible la france n'a pas su
anticiper le coup d'état déjà 12 2020
qui est venu finalement comme une forme
de sanction
face au gouvernement précédent
accusé de corruption est accusé aussi
d'avoir laissé le pape ne pays partira
votre boulot qu en étant incapable 2
comme au congo d'assumer la sécurité
l'ensemble de son territoire je vous
rappelle qu'une démission de barkan
justement c'est de venir en aide aux
nations
donc du g5 sahel pour qu'elles puissent
assurer les services publics qu'elle
puisse reprendre le contrôle de leurs
territoires ce n'est pas ce qui s'est
passé en huit ans de présence de la
france malheureusement et sous la
supervision des français et bien une
partie de ces pays se sont délitées je
dirais qu'à l'exception de la mauritanie
qui aujourd'hui est parfaitement en
contrôle alors qu'il ya dix ans la
situation était critique le mali est
devenu véritablement un état failli le
burkina faso également avec des groupes
jihadistes qui déambulent un peu comme
ils veulent dans tout l'est du pays au
mali se sont véritablement des pans
entiers du territoire qui sont laissées
en jachère qui sont laissés aussi à la
commande
aux mains finalement deux groupes dans
lequel s'exerce des des conflits
ethniques énorme entre les peuls et les
dogons par exemple donc il ya aussi les
activités de banditisme des activités de
kidnapping enfin bref la situation
extrêmement critique d'un point de vue
sécuritaire et barkan qui était venu
justement dans une entreprise de
pacification du sahel on peut le dire un
véritablement échoué le col le général
qui commande la force par cannes l'a
même reconnue donc il était difficile en
effet de d'assurer avec aussi peu
d'hommes la sécurisation la pacification
d'une telle étendue mais la situation la
pire c'est que finalement
avec la présence militaire française et
pendant cette présence militaire
française et bien les autorités
maliennes les autorités burkinabè et
d'une certaine façon aussi au niger
puisque il ya aussi d'aider des zones
critiques au niger et bien ces pays là
n'ont pas réussi à reprendre la
souveraineté totale de leurs de leur
territoire fall au contrôle de leurs
territoires
régis le sommier selon l'elysée les pays
occidentaux impliqués dans la région
hôte entamé je cite des consultations
politiques et militaires avec leurs
partenaires africains pour je cite
arrêter les paramètres de cette action
commune d'ici juin 2022 mais alors ça
c'est du vocabulaire très technique et
très militaire est très politique en
réalité on
depuis un petit moment que une partie
des contingents qui forme notamment la
force takouba les suédois ont été
évoqués tout à l'heure mais également on
a appris que les estoniens qui sont des
partenaires fidèles et plus anciens
lieux de la force française
comment donc au mali avait aller retirer
leurs contingents donc ça c'est des si
vous voulez si on n'a plus les suédois
si on n'a plus les les estoniens il
reste les tchèques en gros et puis
quelques forces spéciales aux italiennes
ou belges mais plus des infrastructures
plus d'autres commando on en a parlé du
canada on a parlé de l'allemagne mais
l'allemagne aussi a dit qu'elle allait
retirer son contingent donc on sent bien
que on arrive à bout et l'idée
aujourd'hui c'est d'arriver et à faire
en sorte que cette force se retire en
bon ordre il ya eu des investissements
colossaux qui ont été faits me barkan
ces 700 millions d'euros par an et les
bases qui ont été construites par la
france en particulier à celle de gao qui
est immense et celle de ménaka qui était
justement venu pour devenir le qg de
takouba héniart ces barrages ont coûté
énormément d'argent il va falloir
qu'elle soit à nouveau
qu'elle soit rendue aux comment aux
autorités maliennes aux femmes a ensuite
après la question va être de savoir si
ces mêmes femmes à vont être capables de
tenir le terrain vont être capables
d'avoir été suffisamment formés parce
que le principe de takouba justement
c'était de mettre des forces spéciales
européennes pour former l'armée malienne
et pour lui permettre de tenir le
terrain de façon à ce qu après on ne met
plus de forces conventionnelles et
progressivement se retient le but de la
france au mali n'a pas été de rester à
perpétuité mais huit ans on sent bien il
ya une forme d'usure il ya une forme de
questionnements de la présence française
par les populations un peu de la même
façon que la présence américaine au bout
de 20 en afghanistan a permis aux
talibans de revenir au pouvoir parce que
les américains sont pas dire qu'elle
n'en a pas on a une pensée à
d'occupation c'est à dire que le mali
sera le prochain afghanistan c'est ça ce
que vous êtes en train de dire aux
pressions bien non je ne pense pas je
pense que le double parallèle peut être
fait sur lui eurent demande d'une
mission qui manque aujourd'hui
la question la france a extrêmement bien
performer quand il s'est agi d'aller
comment éliminer
qui a dit elle a d'ailleurs éliminé la
plupart des chefs oric du mot chao
de commandes aqmi et il irait pu
récemment un sahraoui donc le chef de
l'olivier est donc est la vraie
véritablement eu une action
d'antiterrorisme par contre
malheureusement elle a péché par absence
de contre insurrection absence
finalement 2d capable d'instaurer ce
point de jonction entre l'effort
militaire et le fait de remettre une
administration ne remette des services
publics et de faire en sorte que les
maliens prenne la relève c'est ça tout
le problème aujourd'hui les maliens ne
sont pas capables de prendre la relève
d'où les appels désespérés du
gouvernement malien pourra trouver
d'autres partenaires on parle évidemment
de la smp wagner parce que c'est
vraiment le le point de commander 2 de
conflit aujourd'hui entre la france et
le mali mais il n'ya pas que ça il ya
d'autres partenaires les chinois et plus
récemment le premier ministre cheikh
guèye maïga a appelé une possible
coopération avec les turcs dont on sait
qu'ils sont déjà extrêmement présent
économiquement notamment dans la région
régis le sommier on l'aperçoit à côté de
vous la conférence de presse des manuels
macro ne va pas tarder à commencer on
aperçoit les drapeaux en ya le drapeau
de la france le drapeau de l'union
européenne évidemment le drapeau de
l'union africaine puisque à un sommet
qui s'ouvre à bruxelles entre l'union
européenne et l'union africaine sixième
sommet cinq ans après celui d'abidjan
depuis drapeau aussi du sénégal puisque
ces métiers c'est le président
sénégalais qui est à la tête de l'union
africaine mais cette question sur place
parce qu'on parle on parle beaucoup des
déclarations à venir beaucoup de
spéculations mais sur place comment est
ce que la population malienne vie cela
comment le gouvernement de maliens se
préparent également au départ des
troupes françaises et européennes
je pense que le gouvernement malien
largement anticipé ce qui est en train
de se passer et la la la rupture avec la
france elle est consommée depuis
longtemps il suffit de reprendre toutes
les dernières déclarations du premier
ministre guelma et gars assimile aux
états qui est le président et par
d'assez peu mais c'est son premier
ministre qui parle et on s'est vraiment
que à chaque fois il ya là toujours la
petite pique l'inde est le dernier la
dernière classe a été justement avec le
contingent danois qui est d'un à peine
arrivé sur place ça mais dacca a dû
rebrousser chemin parce que les
mannequins ne l'ont pas autorisé à
pénétrer sur seul à être présents sur le
territoire et à agir donc voilà la
brouille est consommé de ce point de vue
là maintenant moi j'ai eu l'occasion
d'être gt1 comment bamako avant noël et
je peux vous dire qu'au sein de la
population
il ya un double d'un double sentiment
d'abord il ya en effet un sentiment
anti-français qui s'est développée mais
ce n'est pas un sentiment de haine comme
on a pu le voir par exemple sur il n'y a
pas de drapeau français qui sont brûlés
la même façon que on peut voir des
drapeaux américain de brûler donc dans
certains pays arabes par exemple ce
n'est pas la même chose et et les
français qui sont présents à bamako ne
sont pas menacés physiquement donc il y
a en effet une exacerbation dans
certains mais cette manifestation du
sentiment anti français mais il est réel
il est monté à 1 mais il n'y a pas de
haine de la france est en revanche le
problème des maliens c'est qu'il ya
les lez lille comment les groupes armés
terroristes ont ont multiplié leurs
actions dans l'année qui s'est écoulée
et qu'on a l'impression que ils sont ils
agissent de façon impunie donc beaucoup
de maliens disent il y avait tout à coup
bas il y avait comme embarquable
régis le sommier et charles michel on
rappelle à la france ses alliés
européens ainsi que le canada annonce un
retrait coordonné du mali les militaires
européens présents à bamako seront
notamment redéployé au niger toujours
présent avec nous régis le sommier on a
entendu un une question d'un journaliste
africain notamment sur le sentiment anti
français la réponse d'emmanuel mal comme
vous je constate qu'il ya sur les
réseaux sociaux et parfois dans la rue
beaucoup de gens qui expriment leurs
messages anti français qui sont financés
par l'étranger dont la russie un
discours qui vient frapper
également les dirigeants africains donc
selon emmanuel macron c'est de la faute
de la russie signent un sentiment anti
français au mali quelle est votre
analyse vous qui était au mali il n'y a
pas si longtemps régis le sommier je
rappelle que vous êtes grand reporter
pour arte france
non je crois et je crois que la question
du sentiment anti français qui a
toujours le rapport entre l'ancien pays
colonisés et l'ancien pays colonisateur
aux rapports compliqués qui eux puisque
ben le mali a été indépendant dans les
années 60
immédiatement je rappelle où il faut
rappeler ce contexte historique car le
mali comment sous la férule de modibo
keïta à l'époque est devenu un pays
aligné avec l'union soviétique donc qui
a manifesté une rupture justement avec
avec la france mais il ya des liens ont
rapidement été renoué
ce sentiment en effet c'est toujours le
rapport une survivance justement de cet
esprit de du colonisé du rapport du
colonisé par rapport aux colonisateurs
ça ça reste je pense que en effet
comment à la marge ce sentiment peut
être activée par un certain nombre
d'individus qui ont des agendas
politiques la question de devoir la
route si derrière ça je crois que ça
existe depuis pas mal de temps moi je me
souviens que même à l'époque comment en
2013 déjà même si le lait les maliens
beaucoup de maliens me disaient qu'ils
étaient très comme en reconnaissant à la
france ce qu'a dit emmanuel macron
d'être revenu il faut pas oublier cette
époque que la france était venu au
commence
pour elle pour sauver le mali 2 qui est
ce qu'un détail aussi qu'oublie emmanuel
macron c'est que si cette situation on a
vu justement des forces djihadistes
essentiellement des touareg alliée à des
miliciens libyen en tout cas entraîné
formé par des initiales hy bien envahir
le mali c'est à cause de la guerre en
libye que nous mêmes avions comment
déclencher et les conséquences de cette
guerre en libye ils se sont traduits par
une déstabilisation du sahel à grâce aux
armes provenant des déserts seulement de
moammar kadhafi et également grâce à un
certain nombre de deux commandos il faut
pas oublier par exemple qu'un des
principaux chefs d'aqmi et aujourd'hui
enfin des minimes comment lien d'algues
ali est un ancien de l'armée de kadhafi
donc voilà donc c'est aussi des touareg
qui sont revenus dans leurs zones
d'origine avec des armes et ça cette
déstabilisation de l'afrique elle est
directement la conséquence de la guerre
en libye donc ne l'oublions pas c'est un
débat dans le discours d' emmanuel
macron alors maintenant aujourd'hui oui
il existe des des gens qui
instrumentalisent le sentiment
anti-français qui c'est de le faire
comment grandir mais il ne faut pas non
plus le comment le le comment les gsell
gérer les maliens que je vous le disais
déjà ne sont pas hostiles non pas de
haine vis-à-vis de la france ya une
grosse comme une forte communauté
malienne en france avec des échanges
justement important il ya une donne
économique est très important pour le
mali justement entre la diaspora
française et l'économie malienne il ya
des cdd comment des richesses qui sont
injectés dans leurs oeufs dans
l'économie malienne grâce à cette
diaspora est évidemment les maliens
n'ont pas de o2 de ressentiment
vis-à-vis des français donc oui ça
existe
oui à des mouvements qui
instrumentalisent mais ce n'est pas le
sentiment de la majorité des maliens
emmanuel macron qui a dit que wagner est
là pour sécuriser je suis de ses
intérêts économiques
et également donc le pouvoir malien en
place et toujours entendre parler
emmanuel macron peut peut-être l'écouté
il a elle vient d'annoncer la fermeture
des dernières bases françaises au mali
d'ici quatre à six mois on écoute le
présidentissime et damien de la
conférence de presse qui a commencé à
9h15 il est 10 heures 9 donc
pratiquement une heure de conférence de
presse commune
emmanuel macron qui vient d'en terminer
régis le sommier vous êtes toujours ici
j'avais dit tout à l'heure le mali mais
c'est pas forcément que le mali 1 c
c'est toute l'afrique régis le sommier
qui vient de nous quitter qui est de
retour un problème de connexion vous
êtes toujours là à régis le sommier je
disais tout à l'heure le mali mais pas
forcément qu'est mali c'est toute
l'afrique ici tout une stratégie globale
qu'est ce qui va se passer désormais
selon vous emmanuel macron qui a récusé
la notion d'échec notamment tout à
l'heure il a répondu à la question d'un
journaliste comment est-ce que vous
analysez cette réponse d'eads emmanuel
macron la france n'a pas failli
égouttez la france a échoué en tout cas
dans la pacification du sel ça c'est une
évidence et je pense que voilà au bout
de huit ans on peut considérer la
situation sous note subit donc s'est
dégradée dans la région et en
particulier au mali je ne nie pas le
fait que le niger est un pays qui arrive
à peu près à s'en sortir encore que la
zone des trois frontières ne l'oublions
pas concerne évidemment le niger le
liptako dans son ensemble cette région
est complètement
comment infiltrés par des groupes
djihadistes au niger c'est la base
arrière de l'olivier est ce donc de
l'état islamique dans le grand sahara
c'est là où il opère la zone de tango
tango la zone de tillabéri toutes ces
zones qui sont à quelques centaines de
kilomètres au nord de niamey c'est là où
se trouvent les plus durs des
terroristes donc de leur hygiène ce qui
est un groupe comment extrêmement actif
ensuite vous avez au nord plus dont
comme alix en effet baqim y est vous
avez d'autres groupes qui évoluent dans
la région donc regroupées sous là ce
qu'on appelle les nîmes donc oui dire
commencer l'évacuation effectivement le
départ du mali et quand même quelque
chose un élément quand même extrêmement
conséquent c'est pas une petite chose
offs c'est le comment le coeur du
dispositif
justement de lutte contre le terrorisme
et de la présence française au sahel se
trouve au mali la base de gao est l'une
des bases les plus importantes la base
de ménaka est une base qui vous dire moi
je suis allé en trois ans je suis allé
trois fois à ménaka et à chaque fois je
ne reconnaissais pas tant la base avait
grandi donc à chaque fois c'est une base
qui est devenu incroyablement comment
grande à mesure justement que les
contingents européens de taxes bars sont
venues se rajouter les tchèques lille et
les suédois or on a construit des pistes
des cop terre on a construit un comment
un hôpital ce nokia il ya énormément de
choses qui ont été investi énormément
d'argent qui étaient investis sur le
territoire malien annonçant retirer
aujourd'hui elle n'est pas anodin et
leur déploiement au niger ne l'est pas
non plus puisqu'on a déjà une base
extrêmement importante une base aérienne
donc à niamey d'où partent justement les
des drones ou partie les mirages qui ont
frappé justement les terroristes mais à
côté de ça il va falloir reconstruire
des infrastructures il va falloir en
tout cas si on veut être performant à
nouveau dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme et cette lutte n'est pas
finie elle ne ce n'est pas uniquement
élite évidemment présente au mali mais
en tout cas la plupart des groupes les
plus actifs le sont donc le mali il va
falloir éviter aussi que le mali
devienne un sanctuaire pour les
terroristes si les français ne s'y
déploie plus si les femmes à cette
heure-là forces armées maliennes ne
parviennent pas à lutter efficacement
contre le terrorisme en tout cas faire
en sorte qu' un certain nombre de
groupes djihadistes c'est le baisse les
armes parce qu'il ya aussi ça il ya un
processus de réconciliation qui est en
cours mais un processus de dialogue qui
a été entamée par des autorités marième
malienne depuis plusieurs années avec
ces groupes jihadistes pour essayer
justement de retirer et de les faire
revenir dans le temps dans le l'état
malien et bien si tout ça ne
comment ne se ne se produit pas il y à
un risque évident que le mali deviennent
à nouveau un sanctuaire du djihad un
sanctuaire 2 à partir duquel ces groupes
pourraient frapper d'autres pays le
niger et les pays du golfe de guinée
parce que on l'a bien vu il ya eu des
attentats à grand bassam par exemple en
côte d'ivoire il ya quelques années donc
ces groupes sont capables de se projeter
jusqu'à jusque sur les côtes et le
risque principal c'est qu'ils qu'ils
contribuent à déstabiliser des pays
comme le bénin particuliers qui ont été
évoqués donc il ya un réel risque et
c'est le redéploiement de barkan
effectivement n'est pas alors n'hésitez
pas un échec global mais en tout cas
c'est ce n'est pas non plus une grande
victoire ce n'est pas un bon signe il va
falloir que les la france et ses
partenaires réfléchissent à la manière
est justement de de contourner ou en
tout cas de refaire une équation avec ce
mali qui aujourd'hui est temps comme en
est n'est plus un état avec lequel la
france a des relations cordiales n'est
plus un état avec la fois lequel la
france que la france considère comme un
partenaire
régis le sommier la fermeture des bases
françaises au mali donc se feront d'ici
quatre à six mois selon emmanuel macron
qu'est ce qui va se passer d'ici c'est 4
à 6 mois on sait que notamment il ya un
sommet qui s'ouvre à bruxelles entre
l'union africaine et l'union européenne
qu'est ce qu'il faut en attendre
écoutez
et qui va prendre justement le le le
poids ou en fait la charge de ce
redéploiement on sait déjà que les bases
donc du nord du pays où emmanuel macron
les a évoqués tessalit tu commences elle
de tombouctou ont été fermés remise
kidal tessalit tétons cnooc tous ont été
remises aux commandos français armée
malienne
on parle les militaires français
la dernière c'était comment tombouctou
en décembre aujourd'hui une partie de de
commander des commandes et force qui au
puits qui opérait en particulièrement le
le gosse qui est qui opérait donc les
forces spéciales françaises qui opérait
à partir de tessalit tu ont été
redéployés dans d'autres endroits et en
particulier rue de saad donc voilà il
il ya déjà eu un repositionnement un
redéploiement d'arcade donc une partie
des forces ont déjà été retirés
maintenant la
c3 base trois bases très importantes qui
vont être redéployés ancien je pense à
mettre niger d'action du burkina est
aussi compliqué parce que quand emmanuel
macron met l'accent sur la dont le fait
que le mali a aujourd'hui un
gouvernement de transition qui s'est
engagé à sur un processus électoral et à
donner un calendrier et n'a pas tenu cet
engagement au burkina faso on a eu aussi
un coup d'état on a également un moment
un gouvernement de transition et on a
aussi un autre gouvernement de
transition au tchad ne l'oublions pas la
mort d'idriss deby a vu l'avènement de
son mais c'est aussi un gouvernement de
transition qui c'est qui s'est engagé à
donner un calendrier électoral pour le
moment on met pas trop de pression sur
le tchad en remarque on en met plus sur
le malick sur les autres mais il ya
beaucoup de gouvernements de transition
beaucoup de putsch donc beaucoup
d'instabilité dans cette zone la cedeao
l'union africaine montre affiche un
visage d'unité mais en réalité il ya
encore eu il ya quelques semaines une
tentative de coup d'état en guinée
bissao il ya eu un coup d'état en guinée
également donc on est dans une dans une
période politique est tellement complexe
pour l'afrique de l'ouest et cette
volonté d'afficher une unité mon autour
de la france autour de la cedeao au tour
de l'union africaine est important
symboliquement parce que le pays est là
la réorthe hier à verse une période
d'instabilité merci régis le sommier
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes grand reporter
pour arte france